danielle quiere dar seguimiento a la
tasa de aprobación del presidente de su
país al final de cada mes obtiene
información de una muestra aleatoria de
adultos que apoyen o no el
comportamiento del presidente de su país
y usa una muestra diferente cada mes
daniel quiere probar si la proporción de
adultos que aprueban al presidente es
significativamente menor en diciembre de
lo que era en noviembre cuál de las
siguientes opciones muestra un conjunto
apropiado de hipótesis de la prueba de
significancia de danielle pausa en el
vídeo y tratan de resolver esto por su
cuenta primero veamos una forma de
escribir la hipótesis nula recordemos
que la hipótesis nula es aquella que
supone que no hay diferencia o cambio
alguno así que podemos decir que la
proporción verdadera en diciembre es
igual a la proporción verdadera en
noviembre otra forma de escribir esto
mismo es decir que la diferencia entre
la proporción verdadera en noviembre ya
que en el enunciado nos dicen que daniel
quiere saber si la proporción en
diciembre es menor que la de noviembre
entonces otra forma de escribir esto
mismo es decir que la proporción de
noviembre
la proporción de diciembre es igual a
cero cualquiera de estas dos
afirmaciones expresa una hipótesis nula
válida al ver las opciones tenemos que
la opción a se ve bien la opción b
también se ve bien y la opción se
también la opción de no tiene una
hipótesis nula válida así que podemos
descartarla desde ahorita el enunciado
nos dice que daniel quiere probar si la
proporción de adultos que aprueban al
presidente es significativamente menor
en diciembre de lo que era en noviembre
el cambio que buscamos es que esto se
cumpla si tenemos evidencia de que la
proporción de adultos que aprueban al
presidente es significativamente menor
en diciembre de lo que era en noviembre
la hipótesis alternativa podemos
escribirla como que la proporción en
diciembre es menor que la proporción en
noviembre o también podemos escribirla
como que la proporción en noviembre es
mayor que la proporción en diciembre si
vemos las opciones nos encontramos que
la opción a tiene una hipótesis
alternativa válida en la opción b
intercambiaron esto aquí indican que la
proporción en diciembre es mayor que la
proporción en noviembre que es lo
esto a lo que nos dice el enunciado por
lo que descartamos esta opción la opción
se dice que hay una diferencia en las
proporciones y en muchas ocasiones se
van a encontrar cosas como esta pero en
el enunciado nos dicen claramente que se
quiere probar que la proporción de
adultos que aprueban fue
significativamente menor en diciembre de
lo que fue en noviembre si el enunciado
dijera que está interesado en probar que
la proporción de adultos en diciembre es
diferente que la proporción de adultos
en noviembre entonces elegiríamos la
opción se pero como el enunciado pide
otra cosa entonces elegimos la opción a
veamos otro ejemplo karen tiene un peso
y una moneda de 50 centavos quiere saber
si éstos tienen la misma probabilidad de
caer en águila cuando son lanzados ella
lanza cada moneda 100 veces para probar
si hay una diferencia significativa en
la proporción de lanzamientos en los que
las monedas caen con águila arriba cuál
de las siguientes opciones muestra un
conjunto apropiado de hipótesis para la
prueba de significancia de karen
nuevamente pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta
la hipótesis nula se refiere a que no
hay cambio alguno así que la proporción
de obtener águila con el peso es igual a
la proporción de obtener águila con la
moneda de 50 centavos
la hipótesis alternativa se refiere a
que ella quiere probar si hay una
diferencia significativa en la
proporción de lanzamientos en los que
las monedas caen con el águila arriba a
ella no le interesa si la proporción del
peso es mayor o menor que la proporción
de la moneda de 50 centavos solo le
interesa si son diferentes o no vemos
las opciones y la hipótesis nula de la
opción se ve bien la de la opción se no
es correcta la de la opción b si es
correcta al igual que la de la opción de
ahora nos enfocamos en la hipótesis
alternativa y vemos que la opción de
tiene la forma correcta por lo que la
elegimos como nuestra respuesta
la hipótesis alternativa de la opción a
sería correcta si el enunciado dijera
que la prueba busca determinar si la
proporción del peso es menor que la de
la moneda de 50 centavos y si en el
enunciado dijera lo contrario entonces
la opción b sería la correcta pero en el
enunciado nos indican que sólo nos
interesa
son diferentes es por eso que elegimos
la opción de nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo